okay mm-hmm now let's have a look at
three and I'm gonna start off with C
because it looks really gross but if you
walk through it you'll see it's not that
intimidating okay so for starters can we
just write down the athletic series that
they've got there okay so it starts with
minus 10 minus 3 plus 4 plus dot dot
plus 60 okay now what we're gonna do
I've left it here on the board so we can
refer to it what we're gonna do is try
to use one of these try to use one of
these okay now just for the sake of
giving it a go
I want to see if we can use this one
because I'm given the last turn see that
you're like end on 60 okay so I'm going
to use that fat Shay my Cambridge now
please note with me have a look at the
way we've written a series this
particular formula requires three piece
of information it requires n it requires
a it requires L which of these do we
have just visible on the surface out of
the three I've got air now there's a
there's L in fact I'd love you to write
that with me here's a and here's L okay
what I lack is and how many terms are
there I don't know so here's the way
we're going to do it we're going to look
at this L right this is the same as the
nth term okay and I can use this formula
that we've already worked with to work
out how many times there watch turn N
equals this a plus n minus one lots of
the common difference and that's what
I'm supposed to end on okay this is the
answer so what's the first term again
you told me it's right there it's minus
10 I don't know what n is that's what
I'm trying to solve for so I just leave
it there it's a bit of a messy in and
then what's the common difference you
can read that off it's seven right are
we adding or subtracting we're adding
and obviously sometimes you're
subtracting the series is getting
smaller but in this case I'm just gonna
go seven on the end it okay now because
I've gotten rid of every other perennial
I can just rearrange and solve and can
you guys have a go it shouldn't take you
long add 10 to both sides
go ahead and divide through and then
tell me what you get for n 9 then minus
1 lots of 7 equals 70 you see I just
added yet it divided through which gives
me 10 and then we do the final addition
there we go BAM 11 okay so now that I
know what n is I can go straight up here
and go okay there's my n 11 on two times
first turn how do I finish this first
term minus plus plus plus I put together
the two things to make me call them
right so that's plus 60 so there we go
11 on two times help me out thank you
okay
braids are still in gear they're not
overheating just yet and then we can go
from here 11 lots of 25 that sounds like
252 plus 25 is 275 nailed it okay you're
talking about where's the 2a in my
equation here you're right because
that's this one yeah that make sense in
fact one of the A's is hidden in here
there's an A and then the other a is in
here see that there's the first day and
the second day is tucked inside the 60
so make sense